Film Courage: Where does our
desire to write come from?
Alan Watt, Author/Screenwriter and [Founder
of L.A. Writers’ Lab]: I think the desire to
write is really the desire to evolve or to by
resolving an inner dilemma by dilemma I mean I
really think that the purpose of story is to
reveal a transformation and a transformation
really involves the resolution to a dilemma and
I think of a dilemma as a problem that can't be
solved without creating a new problem there's two
ingredients to a dilemma powerful design and a
false belief think about that for a second you've
got you've got your protagonist they've got this
powerful desire but they're also struggling with
a false belief so at the core of every story is a
protagonist that wants something that's impossible
to achieve based on their current approach their
current identity does that make sense yeah
so I think the desire to write is really the
desire to resolve our own dilemma I'll give you
some examples of dilemma let's say for example
faith the dilemma of faith is powerful desire
would be I want to believe false belief would
be give me proof then I'll believe success notice
a powerful desire would be I want ambition I want
to be successful the false belief will be I will
be successful when I make a million dollars or
whatever it is but what we want is always outside
of ourselves success is something that happens
outside of myself belief or faith is something
that happens outside of myself I need proof
in order to believe and so what makes story so
powerful is that story really is about reframing
our relationship to that powerful desire in other
words true faith will only occur when we let go go
of our false belief that I require proof in order
to believe true success will only occur when I let
go of my false belief that success is incumbent
upon some outward or some external validation
and true success can only come from within so as
human beings our I believe our desire to write is
really about our desire to understand ourselves
in a deeper way writing is the search for truth
okay well this goes back to what I was just saying
about about resolving a dilemma so when you think
about it problems are solved but dilemmas are
resolved through a shift in perception problems
don't make for interesting stories like I'll give
you an example let's say I get a I get a flat tire
I call car repair they fix my tire problem solved
not an interesting story but let's say I get a
flat tire I'm out in the desert and the car repair
guy drives 800 miles to save me and I'm dying of
thirst and I discover that the guy is the is the
guy who is the man who's sleeping with my wife now
I have a dilemma I want to hurt the man who's here
to save my life now that could be an interesting
story this drive back to civilization all right so
when you wait a second this is going your question
was about the truth well yeah writing us a search
for truth is it my truth or is it an existential
truth the world well what I'm getting at is that
the truth is the story begins with an idea of the
truth and by the end of the story we've reframed
our relationship to that idea of the truth so the
truth might at the beginning of the story might be
I've been betrayed but that's not the truth that's
the perhaps the fact or that's that's that's
my belief but by the end of the story the truth
might be that that I have not been a good husband
and that in in and that by being humbled I'm able
to see something that I wasn't able to see at the
beginning of the story okay or what if you thought
the truth was that your wife was cheating on you
but in fact that was her ne'er-do-well brother and
he needed money because he had a gambling problem
and she didn't want to tell you and he's adopted
and no one ever told you about him in the family
and so the only thing that was bad was that your
wife didn't tell you about a brother that they
were ashamed of because it didn't fit the family
sort of dynamics okay and so what's the what's the
question so you thought the truth was that your
wife was cheating on you but in fact she was not
being honest but it wasn't about that it was the
fact that she was concealing a family member so it
was a lie of omission I got it and the reason she
was doing that was she was trying to protect her
brother or she was also putting on errors maybe
they felt shame you know sometimes the black
sheep of the family quote unquote brings shame
so the family doesn't want to acknowledge that
person I got you so yeah so are are we exploring
whether or not this would be a viable story or
the the truth we're going back to because you
were saying it's about truth so in a sense the
truth was faulty in that because your wife wasn't
actually being oh I see what you're she was not
cheating on you I'm talking about universal truths
I'm not talking about the truth as opposed to a
lie I'm talking about I'm talking about a deeper
understanding of oneself or the world you follow
like the truth the truth that sets me free isn't
that my wife confesses oh this was not a lover
this was a this was a this was my brother the
truth is about the theme all right so the truth
might so let's say the theme is intimacy I want
intimacy with my wife but I suspect that there's
there's a secret there's some wall up right and
so every so the dilemma of intimacy for example
might be powerful desire I want intimacy and the
false belief the false belief might be until my
wife tells me the truth I can never have intimacy
with her but here's the thing there's probably
a reason she's not telling me the truth that has
nothing to do with her brother it has to do with
her fear that of of what whatever my response
will be if there's true intimacy she would take
the risk of telling me this family secret do you
follow so the it's not that she's concealing the
truth it's why she's concealing the truth story
is about a search for meaning okay okay every
well- told story we want the story to build
in meaning as it progresses all right every every
page should be more interesting than the previous
page because we're becoming more invested in the
protagonist's dilemma all right so if all if the
story was simply about why is she lying or pardon
me if the story was just about she is lying and
I wonder if he's going to find the truth that's
the plot the plot isn't going to get you to the
end of the story what's going to get us to the end
of the story is by reframing our relationship to
why she's lying and so both characters are going
to have to if the guy is the protagonist if the
husband is the protagonist he's going to have
to in some way change or grow in order for for
him to understand what intimacy means that make
sense the plot is will he find out the truth the
theme is will he reframe his relationship to what
intimacy means will he in some way humble himself
so that so that she is actually able to tell him
the truth and will the new sort of equilibrium
will the new relationship to each other survive
this this disclosure interesting okay so it's not
about whether hiding a family remember because
she felt shame or she's sleeping with the pool
boy she it's because of her relationship to
being how you may see her or you you wanting
to be a better husband something like that right
here's the thing is that if all that happens in
the story is a protagonist gets what they want
our audience is going to be disappointed what
we care about is the protagonist getting what
they need so we don't really ultimately care
about what they want if Jimmy Stewart leaves
Bedford Falls at the end of it's a Wonderful
Life we're going to be disappointed what we care
about is that he reframes his relationship to what
a wonderful life
means.